[Music]  it was the night before christmas  vacation  and the fun was in full swing you split  our family onto two separate fights mom  the family left for their big vacation  is that everyone the cars are leaving  now but forgot one little thing mum  dad uncle blake  they don't even know i'm here  they don't even know i'm here  my mom and dad have gone to tokyo i'm  totally on my own  you do realize that my ten-year-old son  is at home by himself you just assumed  max was on the other flight we didn't  take a census  we got reports of suspicious people  around 36 lincoln nav  i can't go to jail honey i wouldn't last  30 seconds in gen pop it's where fresh  fish get got nobody here is getting got  and we're criminals i don't think so  this is my house i have to defend it  orange stripe center pocket  [Music]  that did not sound right  i am trying to get home to my son  who is alone  and scared  and he needs his mother  [Music]  yes i do only on disney plus  [Music]  bye